>> THIS GUY HAS FOUR STARS.
I WONDER WHAT MY RATING IS.
HOW THE [BLEEP] AM I A 3.9?
I GUESS I DO MAKE THE DRIVERS
WAIT A LOT.
>> 3.9 STARS?
WHAT IS HE A PSYCHO?
>> I WONDER WHAT MY RATING IS.
3.9?
WELL, I GUESS I DID HIT THAT
KID.
>> OKAY, I GOT TO GET MY RATING
UP TO AT LEAST 4.
I'M GONNA NEED A FIVE STAR
REVIEW.
>> FIVE-STAR RIDE.
YOU CAN DO THIS, PETROS.
>> OKAY, NOW TRY TO FORM A
CONNECTION. ASK HIM SOMETHING
ORIGINAL, THOUGHTFUL. SOMETHING
NO ONE ELSE WOULD ASK.
SO HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN
DRIVING AN UBER?
NAILED IT.
>> IS GOOD QUESTION.
I'VE BEEN DRIVING ABOUT SIX
MONTHS.
>> COOL.
>> NOW YOU ASK HIM A QUESTION.
SOMETHING PLEASANT AND
NON-CONFRONTATIONAL.
WHAT RELIGION ARE YOU?
DAMN IT.
>> OH, I'M NOT REALLY THAT
RELIGIOUS.
I PUT ON SOME MUSIC.
WHAT WOULD HE LIKE...?
>> IS THIS WHAT HE THINKS I
LIKE?
>> HUH?
>> YEAH I LOVE THIS STYLE OF
MUSIC.
>> OR I CAN PUT SOMETHING ELSE
ON?
>> ALRIGHT THINK.
>> AM I RACIST FOR THINKING THIS
IS THE MUSIC HE LIKES?
>> I DO LIKE RUSSIAN TRANCE
MUSIC.
YOU CAN DO THIS PETROS.
FIVE-STAR RIDE.
USE THE MINTS.
PEOPLE LOVE THE MINTS.
YOU WANT MINTS?
>> UM, SURE.
>> AND MINT.
>> OH GREAT.
>> JUST FOR YOU, TAKE AS MUCH AS
YOU WANT.
>> ARE THESE OFF BRAND RUSSIAN
MINTS?
JUST TAKE THE MINT.
>> WAIT, WAIT, I SPILLED SOUP.
>> OH MAN IS THAT
CUBA GOODING JR?
>> WHAT NO WAY.
>> THIS IS A REALLY GOOD MINT,
THANKS MAN!
>> I SAW THAT.
>> HE TOTALLY SAW THAT.
DUDE'S FREAKING OUT.
THINK, YOU NEED TO GET THIS FIVE
RATING.
HOW'S THAT?
A LITTLE SHOULDER MASSAGE.
YOU SEEMED A LITTLE TENSE.
>> IT'S NICE.
>> GOOD YES.
>> YOU SHOULD TOUCH HIM.
>> IS THIS OKAY?
>> SURE YEAH.
>> OOTSIE BOOTSIE.
>> TOOTSIE. NICE.
>> IS ALL ABOUT PRESSURE POINTS.
>> WATCH THE [BLEEP] OUT.
GET OUT OF THE WAY.
WHAT ARE WE EVEN DOING?
>> THIS WHOLE HORSE AND PONY
SHOW TO IMPRESS EACH OTHER.
>> THESE RATINGS HAVE DRIVEN US
CRAZY.
>> IS LIKE EPISODE OF "BLACK
MIRROR" OR SOMETHING!
OH MAN, YOU WATCH "BLACK MIRROR"
TOO?
[ TOGETHER ]
>> THAT'S MY FAVORITE SHOW.
>> WELL, THIS IS ME.
>> HEY.
FIVE STARS.
>> RIGHT BACK AT YOU, BROTHER.
HAVE A GOOD ONE, PETROS.
>> ADIOS, COWBOY.
>> WHOA!
PETROS, WHAT THE [BLEEP]!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]